welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host definition
aka the guy that's still cooling off
after watching the batman trailer for
the 900th time
don't worry though we've managed to
freeze up some time
got a hot exclusive image from behind
the scenes of the movie
new plot leaks to talk about and filming
updates that will melt even the coldest
of hearts
we're also going to be debunking the
apparent quarterback's image so make
sure you stick around until the end
there might be some spoilers here so if
you're a snowflake that gets cold feet
then i highly suggest that you turn off
now make sure you subscribe to the
channel
for batman videos like this every week
and of course
terrible terrible ice puns anyway with
that out of the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
kick some ice
okay so i've sent this image over the
weekend by someone i've been talking to
about the batman movie
for probably the best part of the year
now they've asked to remain anonymous
so i can't say who it is but they're
very close to the production
now normally i don't watermark this
stuff but you know what
there's been some reports the last
couple of weeks that i've just taken
stuff i posted out
not credited me and then they've acted
like the ones who broke the story
now shout outs to everyone who called
this out and yeah it is very frustrating
as i'm sure you know if you watch my
videos i always credit the source
anyway i've bloody watermarked this but
if you're a news outlet that wants to
report on it
just message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers i'll send you it without
the watermark
and all i ask is that you link back to
the video and then that'll be really
nice ice baby
look i'm an idiot anyway as for the
image itself as i'm sure you can guess
these are the gotham city fire
department's helmets the helmets look
pretty worn down
and used and i love the authenticity
that comes with them
now there are a couple of things that we
can take from this and i even have my
own theory about what's going on
if you cast your mind back to a couple
of months ago you may remember that
there were rumors surrounding the film
that said the villain firefly would be
making an appearance
this was further cemented by the casting
of a fire station chief in the film
which seemed to add more weight to it
after seeing the trailer
i can imagine an arsonist type character
that would fit into this world
and though i don't think that he would
have a jet pack i can see batman
tackling someone that's more ground
level
like an anarchy or someone reeves is
clearly taking his universe in its own
direction
and having a fire brigade actually make
an appearance in the movie
to put out a blaze left behind by the
villain i think would be brilliant at
providing some world building
we of course have the gotham tv show
coming up and we definitely need to
start sowing the seeds for villains that
they're gonna tackle
now that being said from the trailer we
also know that the riddler uses
explosives a lot
so if we go at this from the other
probably more likely angle that the fire
department's just here to help with the
destruction he carries out
i can still see this being a nice bit of
costume design
you may notice that the other helmet has
a sticker on it which says true patriot
whilst the bottom one says lucky you
even these minor editions i think add
some characterizations to the costume
and they almost give them a real life of
their own
now whether this confirms firefly or not
i don't know
and in all likelihood it's probably just
a cool bit of costuming
but we do know from this image and the
casting on imdb
that the fire department will have a
more substantial role than simply just
set dressing at the scene of a crime
i love seeing little things like this
and of course i'd love to hear your
theories on whether you think it
confirms
the firefly leaks or if it's just for
world building
now as for the plot itself we've also
had some brand new plot points posted on
dce leaks
that sound like they could have some
truth to them based off of what i know
in the film
as always take these weather and you
know
you know i say this so much that you can
probably say with me
say it pinch of salt but it is quite
interesting
i'll be dropping my thoughts in on this
as we go through it but from what i know
i i'd say it lines up a lot now the post
comes from alfred borden1
and it says the riddler and carmine
falcone are the main villains
catwoman and the penguin are supporting
characters and the movie chronicles
how they become the villains that we
know now this is very similar to the
long halloween
which the film is supposed to be based
upon and in that falcone pretty much
acts as the overlord of gotham running
the mobsters and politicians for his own
personal gain
the book follows on from batman year one
and though there are stories in between
it does have catwoman graduating from
being a simple jewel thief
to someone actually connected to the mob
and it's here that she really builds her
romance with batman
the leak then goes on to say edward
nashton is an engineer who uncovers a
conspiracy connecting gotham's elite
the mayor the district attorney the
commissioner of police
to mobster carmine falcone's efforts to
privatize gotham's essential services
like water and energy
and raise their costs under the pretext
of renovating the city
when he threatens to expose it falcone
attempts to have him assassinated but
they only manage to kill nashton's
pregnant wife
nashton then fakes his death becomes the
riddler
and begins killing the people involved
in the conspiracy leaving behind
clues that expose their lives to the
public now the death of his pregnant
wife
kind of reminds me a lot of the joker's
situation in the killing joke
and though that was an accident that
sent jack spiraling off into the clown
prince
of crime i like the idea that it could
be brought over to the riddler and also
tied to the mob
it does indeed seem like the riddler is
targeting the illy of gotham
and even his jabs at bruce being
connected to it all does hint to the
wanes being involved in some
conspiracies
obviously a lot to unpack from that and
the next part of the leak says
oswald cobblepot is a nightclub owner
and criminal entrepreneur who refuses to
work for falcone
he runs a small operation but manages to
take advantage
of nashton's actions to take over
falcone's organization
once batman takes him down becoming the
new kingpin of gotham
he dislikes being called penguin at
first though he
ultimately embraces the name and has
several street gangs under his command
including the royal flush gang
who are the guys with painted faces that
batman completely wrecks
in the trailer just gonna watch just
gonna watch this bit again
i'm vengeance now this is pretty much
something that we know for definite
whenever he's discussed the character
matt reeves always refers to him as oz
rather than the penguin so it does
indeed seem like he's still a small fish
in a big pond
in the trailer we actually see oz at the
docks doing a very small deal
which then spirals into a gun battle if
he was as big time as he is in the
comics then i doubt that he would be
getting his hands dirty
so he can assume that he's actually
quite far down the ladder at this point
falcone is pretty much a kingpin of
gotham thus it does seem like if he's
taken out in the movie
which he probably will be oz will step
into the vacuum left behind
and finally become the penguin and
lastly the leak says
selena kyle is a thief who targets
gotham's elite after growing up in
poverty
she steals evidence of falcone's
conspiracy and initially
leverages it for her own benefit but
ultimately helps batman to expose it to
the public
after learning how many poor families
falcone would harm
she flirts with batman and is inspired
by him to adopt the identity of catwoman
and the movie implies that she might be
falcone's biological daughter
okay so this is very close to the long
halloween and we actually see sections
of the trailer that line up a lot with
this
in the graphic novel selena at one point
breaks into valconi's penthouse
to steal his ledger and it's here that
she comes face to face with batman who's
after the same thing
we pretty much see this play out in the
trailer too with her breaking into the
mayor's office
and trying to crack the safe before
being stopped by batman
i highly doubt that there's any big
valuables kept in the mayor's office
safe
as these would most likely be kept at
his home
thus we can assume that something kept
in his office safe
likely deals with financial information
selena is clearly after this
and it seems that the batman would be
too if he was trying to unearth the
conspiracy
i can hardly see him just passing the
mayor's office and then noticing her
if she's just there for jewels he's
clearly there for the same reason that
she is
so we can add that whatever's in the
safe is important to both batman and
selena
i definitely think that this post sounds
accurate and though a lot of it might
just be an educated guess
it does make sense from what we know now
as for when filming will resume on the
movie
it looks like things are actually well
underway at the moment
before we get into that though i just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the christopher nolan
collection to one random subscriber
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning it is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the news in the comments
section below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of september
and the set will be shipped out from
then to ever gets the prize so best of
luck to everyone who takes part
okay so you may have seen last week that
there was an image of two batmobiles
posted online
typically film productions tend to do
this when they're putting a car through
the ringer
and they need a backup one just in case
things go to crap
so we can expect some big batmobile
stunts in the film
however there are still a lot of
questions about when filming will resume
in the wake of the pandemic but it looks
like it might actually be underway right
now
i sounded like a bit of a super villain
there but yeah yesterday
alex ferns aka trevor from eastenders
aka commissioner pete savage posted out
a tweet that said it was good be back on
set
and within almost minutes the warner
brothers must have stepped in and
knocked him out
because not only was the tweet gone but
the twitter account itself
i'm telling you those warner brothers
they don't mess about
on top of this zoe kravitz was spotted
out and about in england with her
husband
and she would only really be in the
country if things were still going ahead
production was rumored to be starting in
september but who knows if things were
all in place
they might have actually kicked it off a
little earlier it's good that we're at
least getting the ball rolling again
though and hopefully
there's no more delay to the schedule
and lastly
lastly is the quarterbacks member image
that you might have seen flowing about
this was getting a lot of coverage as
someone that was wearing a mask of the
infamous group
and lots of outlets were saying that
this confirms their appearance
however when you skip to the next frame
in the trailer you can see that it's
just a guy
and the white face was likely just due
to the lighting on set
i do think that the court will be in the
movie but this guy isn't a member
also this isn't me dunking on people
reporting it
i almost made a video myself but i was
just too lazy to that day so yeah
i hope no one has any hard feelings
because god knows
i probably report on false stuff all the
time and
even in this video but if you say to me
mate
i'll knock you out yeah i'll bloody
knock you out
anyway that's the news for the week hope
you enjoyed the video and the
and the threats and don't forget that we
do this sort of thing every week
same bat time same bat channel so make
sure you subscribe for a lot more videos
like this
comment below and let me know your
thoughts on the stories and if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
batman trailer
in which we found 100 details that make
it seem like it's gonna be a die-hard dc
fan stream
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider
clicking the join button below you can
also come chat us on our discord server
linked in the description or heavy
spoilers on twitter thanks for making it
until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]